[Music]
there's so many new beauty products
being released all the time so we
gathered some of the most hyped from the
last month to test for ourselves
first up we have the mad love brow stamp
kit that went viral on tick tock it
comes with five different sized brow
stencils you basically apply the stencil
to your brow and stamp the brow color on
to fill this was surprisingly easy to
use and it is kind of fun to like stamp
on a brow i think i applied a little too
much of the brow color but i liked how
it looked after diffusing the color with
the spoolie my brows are a little sparse
but naturally full so i think a product
like this is definitely better for
people with little to no brow hair
i am so torn on my feelings for this
rebel mascara the brush is a very spiky
plastic that kind of hurt my eyes when i
was applying i didn't like that at all
and the actual mascara formula is so
weird and gloopy but after applying it i
think i liked it it definitely
lengthened my lashes a lot and it didn't
get too clumpy when i was layering it up
it didn't do too much for me in terms of
thickening which is mainly what i look
for in a mascara but if you're someone
who wants length from a mascara you'd
like this but beware of the really spiky
brush
colourpop came out with a new lipstick
formula the glossy lip stain i was kind
of blown away by this the color is so
rich and vibrant i don't know why i
expected it to be sheer but it's
definitely not there was a slight
patchiness that went away with another
swipe of the product the texture is
thinner than i would expect from a gloss
and has a slightly tacky finish which i
didn't mind and before it dries down it
does transfer here's what it looked like
a few hours later when it was pretty dry
down the stain it leaves behind is so
pretty and gives you those like popsicle
lips once it dries down it's pretty
transfer proof i love this and i will
definitely be buying some more shades
i love melt cosmetics and i was totally
mesmerized when i saw these new liquid
highlighters they were releasing
especially this pink one i literally
never wear pink highlighter but this
color was just speaking to me and i had
to have it the glow these give is
intense it looks really good on bare
skin not super natural but not glittery
or too metallic i also love it over my
foundation it didn't break anything up
and it layered really well you can also
wear these on the body or mix them into
your foundation to make it more glowy
these are pricey but because you can
wear them in so many ways i think it's
worth it
i am so not a cream bronzer kind of
person but i've been seeing them
everywhere this one from elf has been
getting great reviews and it's super
affordable so i had to try it the
texture is hard to describe because it
blends from a cream to this super soft
diffused almost powder like finish what
scares me about cream bronzer is it not
being blendable and not meshing well
with my foundation but this one was so
blendable and easy to work with and you
can definitely layer it if you want to
build up the color i love this
i had to get this flower beauty spray
can setting spray i honestly thought
this was gonna go terribly you basically
just shake it up and spray it all over
your face to set the makeup honestly it
wasn't that bad it did set and mattify
my face nicely it didn't have a strong
smell which i was worried about and it
didn't spray powder everywhere what i
don't like about it is that it's hard to
use in concentrated areas like my under
eyes it didn't set that area very well
and i saw my concealer creasing pretty
quickly i think this could be good for
touch-ups like getting rid of oil
throughout the day but not for actually
setting your makeup also the spray is
it's a little aggressive
[Music]
you